the next item of business is first
Minister's questions and at question
number one I call Douglas Ross
thank you very much representing officer
The Daily Mail has today reported that
SMP Minister Jenny go Ruth just sat
behind the first Minister it may have
broken the ministerial code the former
transport Minister who Hamza Yusuf
promoted to be cabinet secretary for
Education change plans that had been
agreed for 18 months with just weeks to
go
the original plans would have seen a
small closure to real services around
her constituency for a few days just
after Christmas last year to allow you
for essential upgrades to happen
Jenny goldruth appears to have forced a
change in order to give preferential
treatment to her constituents at a
higher cost to taxpayers and far more
disruption to passengers does the first
Minister think it's acceptable for a
minister to make a political decision
for her own benefit instead of acting in
the interests of all of Scotland first
minister
can I say to Douglas Ross he is making a
very serious accusations indeed and of
course if there are any accusations of
the ministerial code being broken of
course there will be appropriately
investigated so that's an accusation
that Douglas Ross is making of course
will appropriately investigate it but I
don't believe the way that Douglas Ross
has characterized that particular
situation to be correct at all and
Sunday the 21st of May Scotland's new
timetable uh who came into effect it
will come into effect for this year
that's another important step towards
Scotland's Railways as it continues to
recover so those timetable changes but
these timetable changes of course happen
regularly in terms of when they happened
when Jenny go Ruth was the transport
secretary it was done for the correct
reason certainly from the investigation
that I have done this morning from when
the story as Douglas Ross says has come
into the published Consciousness what I
would say to Douglas Ross of course we
have invested heavily and significantly
into Railway Services we have proudly
taken scotrail back into public
ownership and every decision we make
every decision that any transport
Minister under this government has made
has been to the benefit of the entire
network entire Railway Network including
of course passengers up and down the
country so I don't believe the way that
Douglas Ross has characterized the
situation is how it has taken place but
of course I will investigate the issue
further Douglas Ross well let's just
clear up some of the things first
Minister said there he says he's going
to investigate but then he said he
investigated this morning and sees no
fault in what Jenny goruth did he also
questions my characterization of what
happened so let's just go through some
of the pages and pages of foi emails
that we have seen a Freedom of
Information response makes it clear that
instead of a few days of closures after
Christmas us Jenny garuth pushed for
changes that would lead to six weeks of
disruption including four full weekends
now Jenny goruth is very keen to
intervene here but I'm just reading out
what we have received what Mr Ross if
you just give me a moment I am
absolutely sure I don't need to remind
members of the rules regarding behavior
in this chamber just be grateful if
you'd adhere to those Mr Ross Jenny
garuth seems to have a lot to say about
this so it'd be interesting to hear what
she's told the first Minister because
Scott real advise in these emails that
the plans Jenny got Ruth put forward
would mean that 9 000 more customers
every day would have been disrupted with
her proposals scottriel reviewed the
decision and concluded there would be
and I quote from scotrail greater costs
with more customers disrupted or
inconvenienced with the revised access
plan Jenny garu's decision to scrap
these changes appears to have cost the
taxpayer at least a million pounds
Scottish real Holdings board papers also
released under foi State this
the board is asked to note that Network
Rail and scotrail chose to do the work
at this time precisely to minimize the
number of passengers impacted and
transport Scotland were fully aware and
endorsed this approach
so how can Hamza Youssef defend Jenny
garuth when she went against the advice
of network reel scotrail and transport
Scotland first Minister
well first and foremost whenever
decisions like this are made and I
remember well in my time as transport
Minister it's so crucial that we engage
with communities it's so crucial that we
engage with communities to understand
from them what the impact of any
potential closure will be uh presenting
office and I can hear groans from me the
size of the benches when it comes to
engaging with communities we always
engage with our communities when it
comes to any potential disruption to our
transport Network and the proposed
decarbonization works on the vital rail
line would have caused significant
disruption right across the whole east
coast of Scotland including for
passengers traveling across yes five but
also in Dundee Perth and Aberdeen too
and the former transport
ministered that she was was not
contained everything was being done to
minimize that inconvenience over a busy
festive period of time and of course
rightly people are traveling up and down
the country to see their loved ones
particularly in the context also of some
disruption that's taking place due to
Industrial action at the time and
therefore she rightly in my view as
Network rail to postpone the works which
they agreed to to give time to engage
with the communities which would be
impacted by the closure so to conclude a
presenting officer for me it's so vital
that whoever the transport minister is
whether it was Jenny goruth previously
the current transport Minister that the
needs of passengers should always be
front and center when such decisions are
made and that was clearly the case
evangelia Guru made that decision
Douglas Ross this is getting worse for
the first Minister he's now seeing that
Jenny gold Ruth was right to do this and
he also said that that Jennifer Ruth is
a former transport Minister thought
there were problems with it well we'll
come to another email on the 19th of
October 2022 miscal Ruth understands why
they are doing this but it's not going
to land well so she agreed with the
proposal but she was worried about how
it was going to land with her
constituents she should not even have
been involved in this decision she
should have recused herself because of
the clear potential for a conflict of
interest concerns were raised about The
Minister's actions one civil servant
whose name is redacted in the foi
response said this it might be wise to
be clear why this is appropriate for
Fife in particular because other areas
might expect similar this political
interference may even have forced a
senior executive to resign
Chris Gibb worked in the real industry
for more than 40 years he cheered
scotrail in 2022. he resigned just a few
weeks after Jenny guru's decision after
he advised against the change and in
board papers that we've seen he raised
concerns about political interference
and a quote from Chris Gibb micro
management by Scottish ministers
advisors and officials
inappropriate actions first minister
that was just uh Ross once again
presenting office uh is making really
serious accusations I'm afraid without
any evidence and what he is hoping to do
uh and and he'll do this because he is
undoubtedly desperate it's through as
much mud as possible and hoping that
some of it sticks members
he will throw as much mud as possible
and hope that some of it sticks then
what I would say to Douglas Ross is that
conflicts of interest and the
conservative party are not something are
not are definitely not a combination
I think thank you
and what I would say to Douglas Ross in
response to the emails that he'd read
out of course he is being selective in
what he is reading out what he's
forgetting to mention is that this
disruption which would undoubtedly have
been caused because of these Works
wouldn't just have affected passengers
traveling across five but also Dundee
Perth Aberdeen and other parts of the
network too so absolutely right I would
expect my transport Minister I would
expect any member of the government to
make sure that they are taking account
of all of those who might be impacted
and all of those who might be affected
so what I would say to Douglas Ross is
look at the facts don't just throw
around muds hoping some of it sticks and
speculation frankly it doesn't help
anybody in here certainly doesn't help
passengers that we are committed to and
improving the real Network for Douglas
Schultz
you know what didn't help passengers
because the former transport Minister's
decision she was emailed on the 7th of
November 2022 at 1740 and told by
scotrail that greater costs and more
customers would be disrupted and
inconvenienced with the revised plans at
least a million extra in Associated
costs and 9 000 additional passengers
every day because of the decision she
took so the first Minister can cut out
all that rubbish about standing up for
passengers when it's very clear that the
decision taken by Jenny garuth led to a
poorer service now this looks like a
clear breach of the ministerial code
Jenny garuth is smirking at this and
well she might because the first
Minister already seems to believe she is
innocent but the ministerial code states
that you must keep separate the roles of
a minister and their role as a
constituency MSP this doesn't just look
like there was preferential treatment in
the constituency it looks like a truly
awful Vision that will cost taxpayers
millions and lead to Greater disruption
five months on five months on the
essential works at Jenny goruth delayed
have still not happened this looks like
a clear-cut sackable offense but at the
very least at the very least this needs
more than the first Minister looking at
this over breakfast it needs an urgent
investigation now so will the first
Minister confirm to Parliament right now
that he will launch an investigation
into his Minister today first Minister
am I understanding this is not the first
time this issue has been raised I think
it has been raised uh months before as
well now of course I wasn't first
minister at the time I will as I said in
my response in response douglas douglas
Ross's first question I will look at the
accusations that are being made but what
I would say to Douglas Ross of course is
that Jenny goruth was not and is not
also the MSP for Dundee Perth and
Aberdeen these decisions were taken of
course because they've been affecting
Railway passengers right across the
network and particularly across the
north east of Scotland so with the
information that I absolutely have in
front of me it seems to me pretty clear
the general Ruth made those decisions so
that of course disruption wouldn't
affect more passengers right across the
network that is something I would expect
Jenny goruth to have done at the time is
it something I expect the current
transport minister to do and these
important vital Works particularly
around decarbonization have to take
place how do we do them in a way that
they minimize disruption particularly
during the busy festive period And what
I would say to the conservatives is that
we take the issues of the ministerial
code extremely seriously not something
that could be said about the
conservatives by any relationship
question number two Anna Sarah
[Applause]
presenting officer next month will be
three years since the Scottish hospitals
inquiry was announced and these are the
facts we already know
firstly two children died because of
infections they contracted at the Queen
Elizabeth University Hospital
secondly there were serious failings a
glad you inclined Health Board which
resulted in the Health Board being put
into special measures
thirdly Luis Lawrence whose husband
Andrew died after Contracting
aspergillus was kept in the dark by a
cover-up
despite all of this the chair and the
chief executive of the Health Board
still have their jobs and no one has
been held responsible now this week the
Health Board under the same leadership
has shamefully refused to accept many of
the conclusions of the oversight board
and they've even called into question
the entire basis of the independent
review that exposed fatal infections in
clinically vulnerable children
so first Minister why should people who
refuse to accept even the most basic
facts be trusted to run Scotland's
largest Health Board first Minister say
that Anna salwar has raised these issues
rightly on many occasions and of course
there is as he has already said in his
question there was already a public
inquiry taking place in relation to a
number of the issues that he has I think
it's important that we don't Prejudice
an inquiry that is taking place and of
course wait for the outcome fully in
terms of that inquiry and then of course
appropriate action will be taken in
respect to those issues but of course it
is important and we have made it clear
that it's that we are not waiting for
that inquiry to finish where we can take
remedial action where we can take action
to improve the situation and across a
number of areas that Anna Anna Sowers
right to raise in this chamber that is
being taken and of course my
understanding certainly is that a number
of the oversight board recommendations
have indeed not just been accepted but
but work as well well underway in
relation to some of those
recommendations so it is important that
you know these issues of course are
raised to hear about members right
across the chamber and my thoughts are
with all of those families that have
been impacted and have been affected by
some of the challenges that the Health
Board undoubtedly has faced but I will
continue and I know the health secret
will continue to engage with Glasgow at
greater Glasgow and Clyde Health Board
to make sure that these recommendations
of the oversight board are indeed taken
forward Anna Star Wars I think the first
Minister missed is the point it's that
we are going backwards now because the
Health Board leadership are saying
didn't accept many of the findings of
the oversight board and they now do not
accept the findings of the independent
case review that highlighted these
infections and I think that's the point
that the first minister is missing
because it's Hill secretary Gene Freeman
understood that grieving families needed
Justice she listened to the voices of
families and campaigners and put the
Health Board into special measures and
she established the inquiry but when
Hamza Yusuf took over he was too weak
and easily laid and he lifted the board
at special measures and empowered those
people that failed now less than a year
later the leadership of the board are
trying to rubbish the independent review
and questioning the accepted facts
Kimberly dalick whose daughter Millie
Maine died says that the board is making
the families lives hell and Louise
Lawrence says this
enough is enough patients have been
harmed others lost their lives families
lied to and buried for what to protect
the reputation of Scotland's Flagship
hospital and that of the Scottish
government
so first Minister will you allow will
you allow the leadership of this Health
Board to rewrite the facts and continue
to prolong the agony for these families
first Minister I I won't of course we'll
hold we will hold the Health Board
leadership absolutely to account in
relation to the oversight
recommendations that have been made and
of course the reason why the greater
Glasgow and Clyde were de-escalated in
relation to special measures it was
because the majority of those oversight
recommendations that were accepted work
was underway many of them also complete
and that's why decisions around
de-escalation were made in relation to
patients and those that have suffered
and and of course anasawar again has
raised cases of of Maine of course of
Andrew Florence in that regard I'm
always happy in the cabin secretary for
health uh well and social care but also
be happy to meet with those families
involved but we have brought forward a
number of measures to improve
transparency and making sure that
families do get the answers but
unfortunately in those rare cases things
do go wrong such as the duty of Candor
for example we introduced that
organizational duty of Candor in April
2018 places that legal Duty on all
Health and Social Care organizations to
be open to be honest when something goes
wrong that the patient safety
commissioner that we have committed to
as well in terms of the legislation
being introduced in response to that
important baroness uh cumbullage report
and in terms of whistleblowing we have
made it clear and I certainly made it
clear when I was the cabinet secretary
for Health and Social care that
whistleblowing is an integral and
important tool that should be used by
staff in order to raise concerns where
they feel it's necessary and where it's
appropriate and I met my time as cabinet
secretary for Health and Social care
every single whistleblowing Champion
right across Health boards up and down
the country including the whistleblowing
champion at greater Glasgow and Clyde so
we'll do everything that we can in our
terrible hold of course at the health
board absolutely to account in my
conversations with the leadership of
Glasgow and Clay they certainly
understood the seriousness of the issues
here what we'll make sure we do on
behalf of the people of Scotland in
government is make sure that when things
do go wrong in the rare times that they
do the vast majority of people get a
good service for my health service and
the in the rare times when things do go
wrong we'll make sure that families get
the answers that they've serve and a
Star Wars the first Minister has not
held these people responsible to account
he's empowered those people that failed
these families and frankly and frankly
staff of the hospital
patients have been failed and families
will listen to that answer from the
first minister with rage and think he's
completely out of touch with the reality
they face every single day because six
years into the Scandal and the
established facts are being denied by a
Health Board leadership who are prepared
to do anything to protect their own jobs
but this is what we've come to expect
from this SMP government no one ever
takes responsibility and failure is
rewarded with promotion the tier of the
Health Board still in his job the chief
executive awarded an excellence in
leadership award the health secretary
when the hospital was opened and when
milliemann died now the deputy first
Minister and the health secret and the
health secretary who took the failing
board out of special measures now the
first Minister under the SMP failure is
awarded and competence is excused and
the Scottish people are left suffering
the consequences so first Minister if
you are too weak to stand up for these
grieving families fighting for Justice
how can the people of Scotland trust you
to stand up for them when it really
matters first minister
Tower can spend in any way he wishes to
do so but the people of Scotland of
course have continued to trust the SNP
with the Health Service time and time
and time again and why have they done
that they've done that because we've
invested record amounts into our Health
Service they've done that because
because we steered this country through
the biggest shock the NHS has ever faced
and it's 74-year existence they've done
that of course because our NHS staff are
the best paid here than anywhere else in
the UK so we do value our staff I seem
to remember quite well doing a debate
here when Anna sawar was leading a
debate for labor party on health where
of course staff at greater Glasgow and
Clyde doctors and nurses criticized at
the politicization anasawar was was
doing at the time in relation in
relation to of course the Health Service
here in Scotland so what I would say to
Anna sawars the decision to to to
de-escalate Greater Glasgow and Clyde
was made because of the evidence that we
had in front of us I'm happy for him to
see that evidence once again and to
provide him with detail once again what
we'll continue to do is make sure that
as I say in the rare times that things
do go wrong will continue to make sure
that we do everything in our power to
make sure there's absolute transparency
that families get the answers they want
and I am more than happy as first
minister to meet with the families the
Anna star war mentions that have
undoubtedly been affected by where that
failure has happened
question number three Alex Cole Hamilton
thank you presigning officer to ask the
first Minister for what reason only four
percent of Scotland's sewage discharge
points are monitored compared with 91 in
England first minister
our approach to assessing sewage
discharges is more effective than that
in England Scottish water has completed
a more extensive environmental study
program to Monitor and model the impacts
of its facilities on water quality data
from monitoring is also being used to
determine any actions needed to improve
Scotland's what environment and Scottish
water has already invested 686 million
since 2010 in improvements and has
committed a further half a million sorry
half a billion pounds during 2021 to
2027 this has contributed to CPA's most
recent classification showing that 66 of
Scotland's water bodies are in good
ecological condition that compares to
just 16 percent in England this is in
line with Ames to achieve 81 by 2027.
Alex School Hamilton the problem for the
first minister is that the money he's
identified for those extra monitors and
70 of all dumping Point pipes in
Scotland will still go unobserved
whereas in England every single pipe is
due to be monitored by the end of this
year when on Earth will we catch up look
at what we have discovered in the last
few weeks human waste dumped around
Scotland's best love beaches Wetlands of
international importance and special
protection areas from Shetland to the
Clyde and the first Minister should take
particular interest in the most used
sewage pumping dumping Outlet in
Scotland that recorded 127 releases last
year that's enough to run 100 million
baths and he will know that site well
because it is on the bank of the Clyde
in his own Glasgow Pollock constituency
perhaps that's why he moved to brotty
ferry so can I ask the first Minister
will he commit today to the introduction
of Legally binding targets to tackle
sewage dumping in Scotland fishminster a
move to brought the ferry so my
stepdaughter could see her father more
uh recently so that is actually the
reason why I have moved there which is
not a state secret by any stretch of the
imagination when it comes to the serious
issue that has called Hamilton does
raise we know that combined to overflows
I don't see this issue he is right of
course to raise them in his question to
me but they are also integral that
integral to ensuring the sewers don't
during periods of heavy rainfall back up
and then end up flooding homes they end
up flooding businesses they end up
flooding streets right across our
country and our monitoring is more
comprehensive and I'm happy to provide
also Hamilton with more detail of this
but in terms of the monitoring that was
done by Scottish water I've got a
detailed
the detail of it I can send out School
Hamilton it was done over a number of
years and what it does allow us to do is
is comprehensively Monitor where these
spell overflows are happening but
Scottish water isn't just sending out
his hands or resting on its Laurels what
it has done has published that improving
uh Urban Waters root map that that
outlines how we intend to invest in
Scottish water in the Scottish water
environments we have a number of
projects that are currently underway to
to monitor but also to make sure that we
make improvements to our sewer Network
so it is an issue that we take extremely
seriously and I would end just in the
point perhaps that I started on at
bethesco Hamilton responds to his first
question and that that notwithstanding
the very serious issues at School
Hamilton raises of course our water
quality in Scotland is very very good it
shows CPA's most recent classification
showing that 66 of Scotland's water
bodies are in good ecological condition
compared to 16 in England and we are
aiming to improve that by 81 to 81 by
2027. Mercedes vialba Scotland's natural
environment is not just the Envy of the
world it's also vital to our health so
it's no surprise that reports of more
than 14 000 sewage spills have prompted
protests across the country including in
Stonehaven in my region this Saturday
now in December 2021 Scottish water
vowed to increase storm drain monitors
to more than one thousand by the end of
2024 but according to an foi response
obtained by the eye newspaper as of the
1st of March this year not a single new
device had been installed so can the
first Minister tell us today exactly how
many of these 1000 he expects to see
installed by the end of this year first
Minister
again it was always the plan of course
that the installation program would take
place over the course of this summer
2023 and then into 2024 and so we are
still confident Scottish water remains
confidence confident that we'll have
those 1000 spell monitors in place by
the end of 2024 I'm happy to provide
Mercedes is available with further
detail if she wishes but I go back to
the point that there has been
comprehensive monitoring uh the the the
studies done by Scottish water were done
between 2015 to 2021 we have a very
extensive computer models for example
that can allow Scottish water to
understand when those combined sewer
overflows will spill under what rainfall
conditions for example and what impact
those spells will then have on the
natural environment so there is a whole
host of data because of that extra
extensive work the Scottish water has
done but to answer Mr villalbo's
Question directly we are still confident
that a thousand spell monitors that will
be installed by the end of 2024.
Stuart
to ask us
if you will provide an update on the
work of the Scottish government to
address potentially dangerous cladding
on Residential Properties fresh minister
now the safety of residents is of course
an absolute priority for this government
we're actively decisively reacting
decisively to protect lives through a
program of cladding assessment and
Remediation the current program includes
105 buildings which will each go through
a comprehensive technical assessment
where we expect that the majority will
be safe if that assessment does identify
an immediate fire risk then we both act
without delay as we have already done as
assessments are completed we will agree
plans and take action to deliver full
remediation and this means I also expect
developers to take responsibility to
remediate their building so the public
parse is not needed to do so while I
urge them to do so voluntarily we will
use all of the levers at our disposal
including legislation if necessary to
remediate buildings and to protect
residents co-caps Stuart I thank the
first Minister for that answer and he
will understand that people's lives have
been put on hold and some of them are at
the end of their a tether local
authorities are asking for building
wardens for remediation work developers
are putting safety measures in place
that are severely imposing on the lives
of people living in these buildings and
yet many residents and my constituents
feel that
um a remediation is not moving quickly
enough so first Minister my constituents
just want their lives back what further
measures can the Scottish government
take to further encourage local
authorities and developers to work
cooperatively to remove unsafe cladding
from these buildings more quickly first
Minister the vocab Stuart is right to
make a couple of key points here one is
that the frustration of our constituents
I think constituents perhaps in other
parts of the country too that things do
not seem to move as quickly on the
ground as they would like and I
understand that frustration co-capture
is also right to mention that we are
trying to take a collaborative approach
with developers local authorities and
others in relation to this particular
situation I can understand how worrying
the situation is for those living in
buildings with unsafe cladding that's
why we put the safety and well-being of
residents very at the very heart of the
cladding remediation program developers
must also do the same they must step up
and fix their buildings our preference
has always been that voluntary agreement
with developers getting agreement of the
Accord but let me be clear we are
putting the safety over as residents
first and foremost we'll use all the
powers we have and I reiterate what I've
already said in response to the first
answer to co-capture that if necessary
we'll use legislation too to ensure that
developers do the right thing so we can
get on with remediating buildings in
line with Scottish building standards
question number five Liz Smith to ask
the first minister of what the Scottish
government's response is to a recent
poll that found that more than a third
of people in Scotland would consider
relocating if income taxes were
increased further first Minister the
Scottish government is proud to have the
fairest and most progressive tax system
in the UK consideration of Behavioral
changes are of course a vital part of
our tax policy decisions our evaluation
of the move to a more progressive tax
system in 2018 2019 found no evidence of
significant behavioral change including
cross-border migration and that should
come as no surprise because our social
contract with every citizen goes
significantly beyond the provisions that
are provided in the rest of the UK
includes free prescriptions it includes
free hire education supporting more than
400 000 children eligible for for the
Scottish child payment so we'll continue
on that path of progressive taxation and
of course we'll have robust analysis
behind any changes that we make to the
tax system Will Smith uh thank you the
Scottish Chambers of Commerce the
Federation of small business the
chartered Institute of Taxation The
Institute of fiscal studies Archangel
Investment Bank DJ Alexander Scotland
are just some of those warnings the
dangers of widening the tax differential
with the rest of the UK and Sandy Bigby
of Scottish Financial Enterprise is
warning the resulting effects on
Scottish productivity and economic
growth so can I ask the first Minister
will he give a categorical assurance
that he both accepts and understands the
widespread and serious concerns amongst
the business community and that the
future tax policies Scottish government
should be fully focused on making
Scotland the most competitive part of
the UK rather than the highest tax part
in the UK first minister
what was fascinating from that uh
question from Les Smith if she didn't
mention a single anti-poverty campaigner
in the list of people that she mentioned
why was she not because of course if we
want to invest money in tackling poverty
then we have to have the money to be
able to do so and that's why progressive
taxation that allows us to of course
increase Revenue to spend on poverty
measures or tackling poverty is so so
crucial what I would say to Elizabeth of
course we'll listen to those
organizations many of them I have
already met already and we will continue
to listen to them at where we possibly
can but we will have robust analysis
robust analysis behind any decision that
we make in relation to taxation I don't
and have never seen a conflict in my
mind to Growing the economy something
that is front and center as part of the
prospectus that I uh that I published in
the first couple of weeks of being first
Minister I see no conflict in growing
the economy and also ensuring that you
have a progressive tax system so that
you can based as I say an anti-poverty
measure so we'll continue to make those
very careful balanced decisions in
relation to taxation we'll make sure
we're informed by robust analysis and
evidence from many of the the
individuals and organizations the list
mentions of course also from the
Scottish fiscal commission as well but
of course if we had listened to
Elizabeth if we had listened to the
conservatives if we had given tax cuts
to the wealthiest then we would have
much less money to spend on things like
free prescription charges on of course
ensuring that educate higher education
is free and of course that game-changing
Scottish child payment settings I've
[Applause]
data shows that regardless of tax rate
changes Scotland continues to attract
more working age people from the rest of
the UK than move in their own Direction
about 20 percent more on an annual basis
and in fact and I know that while the
government will do the due diligence and
sensitivity analysis for any proposed
tax changes can I I make the point that
a modest increase in inward migration
from the rest of the UK to Scotland
could significantly increase tax
revenues by hundreds of millions of
pounds potentially to spend on public
services in Scotland and support
Scottish businesses with skills and
they're detecting their challenges so
you can ask why is the Scottish
government doing to proactively attract
more workers from the rest of the UK to
come and live and work in Scotland first
Minister that's an excellent point made
by Ivan McKee and I'm not sure why the
conservatives are laughing from the fact
of course thank you members
they don't like to listen to the facts
and the facts of course as Ivan McKee
has presented them are absolutely right
we have seen that mortise increase in
inward migration from the rest of the UK
and that is an important Point
Scotland's record and inward migration
from the rest of the UK dispels much of
the hysteria from the conservative party
on the impacts of our tax policy but
it's important to recognize what more we
can do which is why we are committed to
establishing a talent attraction program
and migration service for school that
will help us to build upon the success
that we've had already in this space the
talent attraction and migration service
will improve Scott's ability to attract
and recruit workers from outside
Scotland with the skills that our
economy needs and supports International
workers in that migration and relocation
process what we'll also do is ensure
that of course where we have the levers
overpay over terms and conditions that
we're embedding Fair pay that we're
ensuring that our staff are some of the
best paid in the UK we will do that for
example we are doing that in relation to
the NHS where our NHS staff are the best
paid anywhere in the UK so that helps to
hopefully attract them up here in
Scotland so we'll put progressive
taxation and fair pay at the heart of
everything we do in the Scottish
government for any stark contrast to the
approach taken by the conservatives in
England
question number six Monica Lennon
thank you presenting officer I defer to
my register of Interest as I'm a member
of the GMB Trade union to ask the first
Minister whether the Scottish government
will reintroduce the social Care staff
support fund or take other action to
improve sick pay provision for social
care workers in light of reports of a
survey by GMB Scotland
stating that 80 percent of social care
workers in the private sector have
considered quitting and widered warnings
that the care sector is on the brink of
collapse first Minister let me
recognized that Monica Lennon has often
rightly raised these issues around adult
social care in particular and that of
course the issue series are incredibly
important covid-19 we all know it
created an enormous challenge for the
social care sector in the United Kingdom
right throughout the UK and of course
including here in Scotland that is why
we introduced the social care support
staff support fund to support the
workforce and protect our most
vulnerable people I want to thank social
care the social care Workforce for all
the vital work that they have done in
the course of the height of the pandemic
but also of course that they currently
do in in still under extreme pressure
and significant challenge our fund
continued for longer than any other UK
Nation but it was always a temporary
measure particularly when self-isolation
at rules were in place Fair work is
Central to improving recruitment is
Central to improving retention and staff
well-being in the sector so we'll
continue our work to promote these
practices and improving pay and
improving conditions and indeed the
workers voice to that end we've
guaranteed an additional 100 million
pounds to uplift P to 20 to 10 pounds 90
which took effect from April this year
made a commitment to reaching 12 pounds
an hour for adult social care workers
delivering Direct Care
Michelin
caterers in legality their colleagues
and the people
therefore deserve much better than this
first minister
crisis and social care is getting worse
by the day as highlighted in the Sunday
post carers are urging the government to
reinstate the funds because they cannot
afford to get sick removing this
financial safety net now without an
alternative solution will accelerate the
collapse of social care and push the NHS
further into crisis so hard credit Gene
Freeman listen to the workers worked
with Scottish labor to introduce the
funds in the first place
meet with the workers and their unions
and do the right thing first minister
of course we'll be happy to meet with
children as we do that on a regular
occasion all the cabinet secretary for
Health and Social care uh we'll do that
and of course I'm happy to continue my
engagement uh with uh trade unions and
we are taking action to address uh pay
that is why we funded a further pay
increase to the to the tune of 100
million pounds this uh Financial year
but it's also why of course the work
that's been done through the national
Care Service in order to introduce that
legislation get a national Care Service
up and running to me is so vital because
at the heart of the national Care
Service Our Fair work principles is
sectoral bargaining for example now
we're not going to wait for the national
care service to be in place there's
already work that is going on Through
the Fair work and social care group
they've developed a set of minimum
standards for terms and conditions that
reflect Fair work principles these
standards do include sick play sick pay
they do include maternity and paternity
pay to assist with recruitment in the
sector but that is exactly why we want
to make a continued progress with the
national care service because we do have
because of the landscape of adult social
care in the country with private
providers with in-house local Authority
providers with third sector providers it
is fragmented how much better to have
National consistency right across the
country and we can only really do that
with the national care service
move to General and constituency so
verees I would ask for brief questions
and responses and I call Megan Gallagher
thank you presiding officer Scotland's
social care Watchdog has said children
as young as 12 are allowed to consent to
puberty Brokers this guidance fails to
acknowledge the interim cash review of
gender services in England which
identified several feelings in the
management of the Tavistock Center and a
lack of evidence supporting the use of
puberty blockers more and more Brave
young people are coming forward to talk
openly about detransitioning they're
harrowing stories of surgery and the
lack of mental and emotional support
they received so can the first Minister
clarify if he supports Purity blockers
being prescribed to 12 year olds first
Minister well I support these decisions
being made by clinicians being made by
those who have clinical knowledge that
is what we should be doing we should be
trusting those with that clinical
expertise as opposed to standing up here
in the chamber where we don't have those
expertise making judgments about what is
best for young people who are in need of
gender identity services in terms of in
terms of the cash review that is an
interim report I think it's well
understood that Health Service in
England and Scotland do differ quite
significantly be well of course we have
of course taken account of the interim
report we will look to see the final
report once that is ready too but I go
back to my initial point it's so
important presenting officers presenting
officer that we trust clinicians those
with the medical expertise and knowledge
on such important decisions
education policy at board meets today to
discuss school provision for children in
Dar gavel following the councils
catastrophic School role miscalculation
the last time I raised this the expected
cost to fix the mess was 20 million
pounds it is now an incredible 75
million pounds parents are looking for
the Scottish government to help resolve
this situation there's a first minute
agree that Norwich held in Memphis
should have to pay for the council's
incompetence and lose out because the
resulting shortfall in school budgets
and if so what will the Scottish
government do to ensure there's
accountability for this failure and that
the appropriate primary and secondary
provision is in place as a matter of
urgency first Minister well I will ask
the current education secretary to make
sure that we well discussed and have
those discussions between for sure where
we can I know the previous education
secretary was involved any discussions
these are of course local Authority
matters now what the obedience asking me
to do is take money out of the current
School building uh program and of course
redistribute that to another project now
he would have to say what school we
would take that away from because of
course every single penny is accounted
for in terms of the current budget so
yes we will continue to have uh
discussions with REM for sure Council as
we have done already but I will ask the
education secretary to retouch base with
rembrusher Council because ultimately I
agree with new baby's premise that no
child should feel that their education
or their educational attainment suffers
as a result of any decision that's made
be that by national government or indeed
by local government
Audrey nickel
thank you the first Minister will be
aware that this week marks mental health
awareness week which has a particular
Focus this year on anxiety so as the
cost of living crisis deepens and
household bills are soaring can I ask
the first Minister what action his
government has taken to mark this
important period
first Minister we know poverty is a key
driver of per mental health we're
prioritizing work to support those who
are the most at risk as part of Mental
Health Awareness Week the minister for
social care mental well-being sport met
with money advice and mental health
organizations just yesterday to hear
firsthand the impact the cost of living
crisis is having on Mental Health in
Scotland we've developed advice for
Frontline advisors we've created
resources for the general population on
the mind-to-mind well-being website and
we will continue to work with money and
indeed Mental Health Partners to look at
what more can be done we continue to do
everything we can to urge the UK
government to use all of the powers at
its disposal to tackle this cost of
living crisis because of the serious
impact is having on mental health of the
population
Miles Briggs thank you president officer
whistleblowers and campaigners have
called on the first minister to support
an independent inquiry into the
mishandling of complaints surrounding
Child Protection here in Edinburgh East
Lothian the borders and aberdeenshire
campaigners believe that a wider
independent inquiry is now needed to
investigate safeguarding concerns and
the way reports from parents Guardians
carers professionals and the public have
been mishandled into in relation to
ongoing unresolved child abuse and Child
Protection concerns the current ongoing
Scottish child abuse inquiry remit is
narrow and only focuses
on historic abuse and specifically to
Children living in care so can I ask the
first Minister if you firstly agree to
meet with me personally and campaigners
to discuss their concerns and this and
also whether or not the Scottish
government will take forward an
independent inquiry now into these
concerns first Minister I will ensure
that the appropriate Minister does meet
with miles brexit of course I'm more
than happy to uh to also consider a
request that comes from Miles Briggs
representing the families and should be
credited to males breaks he's Visa issue
on a number of occasions in this chamber
on behalf of those families that have
been affected and this government takes
the issues of child protection uh
absolutely seriously but in reference to
the the issues that Miles Briggs has
raised as I've said I'll ensure that the
appropriate Minister does meet as soon
as possible and I'll also consider an
invitation to meet for all Miles Briggs
and the families involved Mark Roscoe
thank you in the middle of the cost of
living crisis and Andrews University is
increasing rents in their student Halls
by eight percent students are at risk
are being plunged into poverty as the
university lines its own Pockets does
the first Minister agree with me that a
rent increase of this scale is
completely unacceptable will he join me
in calling on the university to reverse
this decision
first Minister well again of course this
is a decision for the University to make
but I can completely understand why Mark
Russell does of course raise this
important issue and we have introduced
legislation as Mark Russell knows uh
only to realm relation uh to ensuring uh
Fair uh rents when appropriate but there
may be areas where we can go uh further
so we are exploring that quite actively
uh what I would say to Mark Russell is
where I agree with him that everybody
including of course our fantastic uh
hire and the further educational
institutes but higher educational
institutes in this case should
absolutely be aware of the
responsibilities that they have in terms
of students who are undoubtedly
suffering from a Westminster cost of
living crisis which is impacting
everybody but particularly of course
impacting on our students
that concludes first ministers questions
the next item of business is a member's
business debate in the name of Rona
Makai and there'll be a short suspension
before the debate begins
foreign